- What's up?
We're back with the cast
of Abbott Elementary!
Quinta Brunson, Sheryl Lee
Ralph and Lisa Ann Walter.
(audience clapping and cheering)
It's amazing how much of school we forget
by the time we're, you
know, older. (chuckling)
(audience laughing)
Makes you wonder how we'd do
on an elementary school pop quiz,
if we had to take one
right now, which you do,
'cause I'm making all of us.
(guests laughing)
Because it's time to play:
"Just how fast can you pass this class?"
- [Sheryl] Oh God.
(gentle music)
♪ Just how fast can you pass this class ♪
- Woo!
- Oh my God! (laughing)
(audience laughing)
I had not heard that, I'm very into it.
All right.
Teams are me and Sheryl.
We are not confident.
- We're not confident.
- Versus Quinta and Lisa.
- Woo!
- I am extremely confident.
- We're very confident, very competitive.
- We're just keeping it real over here,
okay.
- Thank you.
- Here to host, please welcome
one of Quinta's fellow Philadelphia girls
and star of "The Office,"
you can see her and Jane Lynch
on their "A Swingin' Little
Christmas" tour this December.
Here's Kate Flannery, everybody.
(audience clapping and cheering)
(upbeat jazzy music)
- No favoritism, no
favoritism, no favoritism.
- No favoritism, I love it. (laughing)
Well, thank you for hosting.
- Thank you!
- Okay, will you please explain the game?
- This is how, this is
actually what's gonna happen.
It's a super fast test to
measure how much you remember
from elementary school.
- Nothing.
(everyone laughing)
- Oh, no.
I will read two real quiz
questions from each grade.
Each grade's questions are
worth that many points.
For instance, third grade is three points.
You get it, right?
- [Quinta] Okay, okay.
- Is there money involved?
(audience laughing)
- [Sheryl] No.
- Some incentive? No?
- Okay, if Quinta and Lisa win,
they get their photo up on
"The Chicks Wall of Champs
who beat Kelly Clarkson."
(audience clapping and cheering)
(triumphant music)
- Dumb wall, it's a dumb wall.
- She's very competitive.
- What? Never.
- Me too, but I always lose so-
- Yeah, but I don't mind,
but you gotta just be competitive.
- I watch the Emmys, I think
you won, I'm just saying.
- Part of this career is
losing on game shows on TV,
(all laughing)
and I'm tired of it.
- All right, class.
I need your attention.
- Okay.
- Here we go.
- Yes, teacher.
- Starting-
Okay, starting with third grade.
Three points per question.
Here we go.
Ducks fly south for the winter.
This is an example of what behavior?
(buzzer ringing)
- Migration.
(bell dinging)
(audience clapping and cheering)
- I didn't hit it fast enough.
(all women talking indistinctly)
(audience clapping)
- And here's the second
third-grade question.
Okay.
What is the area of a rectangle
with the base of four inches
and a width of five inches?
(buzzer ringing)
(timer ticking)
Lisa.
- 20 inches.
(bell dinging)
- Yeah, right?
(audience clapping and cheering)
I was too nervous.
I was like, "Don't look dumb."
So I didn't press it and
I was, thought 20, damn.
- You should do
more game shows, Lisa.
- It was five times four.
- She does.
It's the reason I became a writer.
(all laughing)
- All right, here we go, fourth grade.
Okay, here we go, fourth grade.
- Oh God.
- Okay, the first 10 amendments
to the Constitution are
also known as the what?
(buzzer ringing)
- The Bill of Rights?
(bell dinging)
- You are correct.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- I'm gonna start getting more bold.
I'm gonna start getting more bold.
'Cause I think I'm right
and then I think I'm gonna look stupid.
- I just like standing
next to the winner.
- You have two sports Emmys.
- [Kate] Yes, exactly.
(all laughing and clapping)
- Stupid? How dare you?
- Just another reason to
drink, ladies and gentlemen.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- Okay, one more fourth grade question.
Here we go.
- [Sheryl] Fourth grade.
- How do you spell manatee?
(buzzer ringing)
- I got it.
M-A-N-A-T-E-E.
- That's it.
(musical trill)
(bell dinging)
- She's right.
- You are correct.
Quinta is correct.
- We got that.
- I didn't know that.
- I was about to be like,
M-A-N-I-S-S-I-P-P-I.
- That's Mississippi!
(bell ringing)
- Wait, what does that mean?
- [Kate] It's such a close game
and now we're at an extra credit question.
This is for the whole megillah.
- Here we go.
- Okay, okay.
- All right.
Pennsylvania is known as what?
(buzzer ringing)
(hands thumping)
- The Keystone State!
- You are correct!
(Quinta screaming and clapping)
(bell tinging)
(audience clapping and cheering)
(air horn honking)
(women talking excitedly)
- I finally won a show!
- She finally won a show!
- Now you want to work!
(audience laughing)
- No, here is the difference though,
'cause I saw it in my
peripheral vision. (laughing)
Yours was like, yours was so grand.
It was like woo!
And hers was like boop.
(buzzer ringing)
And yours was so grand,
it took a little longer.
- I had to.
- Can I just tell you,
'cause I was there that night,
this is way more excited than
she was when she won the Emmy.
(all laughing)
- She was so stealth.
(hands banging on table)
- Quinta and Lisa go to
the head of the class!
Please clap!
(audience clapping and cheering)
You did it! You did it! You did it!
Yay!
- Yay!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- We're so happy for y'all.
- Sorry guys.
- Um, sort of, kind of.
And since Quinta and Lisa are
smarter than fifth graders,
and obviously Sheryl and myself,
their photos will go up
on "The Chicks Wall of Champs
who beat Kelly Clarkson."
(audience clapping and cheering)
Congratulations.
(audience clapping)
A big thanks to Kate Flannery
for hosting, everybody!
(everyone clapping and cheering)
- [Sheryl] A legend.
- You can see Kate and
Jane Lynch perform songs
off their hit holiday album,
"A Swingin' Little
Christmas" this December.
Check online for tour dates
and of course, watch Abbott Elementary.
Wednesdays on ABC.